[Music]
welcome to our 2022 lab root series my
name is leah lavery marketing manager
for life science electron microscopy
from thermo fisher scientific and your
moderator today
welcome back to any returning attendees
to our webinar series and a big hello to
new attendees wherever you are in the
world
prior to electron microscopy reached
single atom resolution in 2020 enabling
the location of individual atoms in a
protein to be determined for the first
time
since 2020 researchers have been
investigating the protein structures of
sars code v2 ion channels human membrane
proteins hiv and tau filaments
today's presentation is titled tail of
amyloid filaments and neurodegenerative
diseases we were given by my colleague
abhay khattacha and our special guest
speakers yanxi and sophia lovestam from
the mrc
laboratory of molecular biology
after today's presentation there will be
a q a session please submit your
question at any time through the q and a
window
let me now introduce my colleague alpha
catastro applications group manager to
start us off
apai received his phd in structural
biology at the university of oxford uk
he spent further time at oxford as a
postdoc continuing a position as senior
research scientist
apai has been with thermo fisher
scientific for over two years and an
expert in single part analysis micro ud
and cryo electron democracy
thank you leah for this wonderful
introduction uh and hello everyone as
leia said i am apeco teacher
and today i am going to talk to you
about how we are using electron trio
microscopy in neurodegenerative diseases
this talk is in collaboration with our
partners at mrc laboratory of molecular
biology in cambridge uh and later on you
will hear this wonderful tale of amyloid
filaments and how we solve some of the
very difficult structures of
tau filaments
using cryo-em
through yangxi and sofia lowstem
so let me begin by saying that um
i think
most of us now know that cryo-electron
microscopy uh has come quite a long way
uh in in the last few years since since
the introduction of direct electron
detectors
and nowadays we are getting higher and
higher resolution structures almost
every day with this method and and this
is because of very stable microscopes
very good energy filters direct electron
detectors but also because of very good
data processing softwares uh it's a
combination of this two which is
allowing us to answer such uh difficult
uh structures uh using uh the method
even very difficult uh small sub-hundred
kilodata proteins which just few years
ago would would be thought to be
impossible to sold by uh cairo em we can
now actually solve them at very high
resolution so here we have a
streptavidin uh going to 1.7 angstrom uh
hemoglobin at two angstroms uh membrane
protein from sas co2 which we published
just last year in nature structure and
molecular biology
also going to 2.1 angstrom uh and a
human potential partition channel at 2.5
angstroms uh and by summer this year we
have another five membrane proteins uh
again sub 100 kilo dalton from human
origin uh all of them are going to sub
2.5 angstroms uh so this is this is how
far we we have pushed the cryo em uh and
for today's talk
i'm going to talk about how how we are
leveraging this method
for answering diseases and especially in
this case neurodegenerative diseases
now yanxi and sofia will go into much
more details
i'm just going to give you a brief
summary a very high level summary of
what we are doing
most of us would be aware about
alzheimer's disease as well as
parkinson's disease and also dementia
all of this
diseases are collectively called as
neurodegenerative diseases or also
tauropathies
and and they they all come to
malfunction in a single protein uh this
tau protein which which is present in
our body in all of us uh in its normal
form it's essential it uh helps uh
stabilize the microtubules microtubules
are like a trek the roads uh in our
cells where all the other proteins are
traveling
but when there is some malfunction when
there is some mutations uh it leads to
aggregation of distribution in the form
of filaments and this is what is called
as taopathis and this single protein
malfunction in the single protein leads
to more than 20 different types of
neurodegenerative diseases
so
last year
our collaborators are lmb cambridge uh
sure shares and michael kudat uh as well
as young she who was working on this uh
project uh discussed with us that they
have this protein uh psp or or protein
from a patient who suffered from
progressive super nuclear policy one of
these neurodegenerative diseases coming
directly from the brain of this uh
person uh and and they're not able to
get high resolution they're stuck at
about four and a half five angstroms
can we use selectors falcon for uh c
factories to push the resolution forward
so we just collected one data set with
this sample and from this single data
set we managed to solve three different
structures uh with with the structure of
this psp going to 1.9 angstroms
and and along with that young she
actually worked on some 40 different uh
structures and managed to classify do
the structure based classification of
tower paths using this kind of high
resolution structures and you will see
in his talk that that once once they had
this very high resolution structure they
found out actually that this this is
forming the new class of disease it's
not actually directly the psp fold which
was initially thought so again with kyo
em we we can actually find once once you
have such kind of atomic resolution
structures you can actually find more
detailed uh structure which allows you
to identify your diseases
similarly uh using falcon 4i
we worked on another uh structure this
is amyloid beta 42 filaments which is
considered to be a central part of
alzheimer's disease formation and
progression
um here again it's it's it's also
technological advanced uh what we did
was uh we use very high flux on the
falcon 4i data was collected at eight
electrons per pixel per second uh and uh
throughput of 570 images per hour uh and
using such trip with such flux uh within
about 14 hours of data collection uh we
managed to get two and a half angstrom
structure and then they can understand
how this structure is forming and this
this this work was also recently
published came out in science uh i think
in in february uh this year
so again with kyotom we are able to
solve this kind of difficult structures
now i'm coming again back to this slide
which i showed you earlier uh that this
single gene
is responsible for
multiple diseases
but then how how how does it work uh how
can a single
gene
mutation in different parts is leading
to so many different diseases uh so then
again with our collaborators they wanted
to know that which part of this gene is
responsible for which kind of disease uh
we we design a project to do some high
throughput uh structures of cow
filaments and also in vitro so that um
we can kind of if if we can form a
similar structures that are found in
brain in vitro uh then you can use this
system uh in the lab uh to to study uh
therapeutics against it and sophia loves
them will will show much more details on
on how this was done
but we what we use was a combination of
glacious uh endocrines together uh to do
very high throughput structure
determination
and for this so this is like really gene
two structures uh sophia came up with
lots of different constructs as well as
different conditions of different souls
different ions uh and
uh using epu multigrid on glaciers we
actually looked at some i don't know 100
different samples
of this in in a fully automated way
and the way it worked was like this so
this is epu multigrid
we run a session consisting of either
six to eight samples at a time uh and we
collected about two thousand images on
each of this data in a fully automated
way so every time uh 2000 images were
collected uh sample was changed
and data was collected onto a new sample
and this is what you are seeing here
this is the epu multigrid on all this uh
different constructs you can also
already see that filaments are looking
different on on these different
constructs
and sophia analyzed all of this data uh
and managed to produce 76 different
structures and establish this whole
model system to study alzheimer's
disease in retro within the lab and this
was just fantastic work because um
how many papers have we seen which has
76 cryo-em structures all of the data
was collected in eight hours uh six to
eight data sets per run and within 15
days we had all this uh data collected
for them
and in in about six months uh they
managed to solve all the structures and
also that led to a publication
so with this uh i would now uh pass on
to yangxi
to give us more details on how he did
structure-based classification
on taopatis
thank you
hello
uh
many thanks for the further introduction
and i'm young i'm from mrc laboratory of
molecular biology and today i'd like to
show you our recent work which is about
structure-based classifications of
toxics
the abnormal aggregation of tau is the
homework of multiple neurodegenerative
diseases that are actively called topsis
due to the alternate release splicing
there are six types for express in the
out of human brain
uh three of them have
three of them have four magnitude band
repeats we call them for
full repeater and three of them have
only three negative bending repeats
which we called repeater
based on the axon definition of the
target fusion in each disease the
topside can be classified as
three are plasma autopsies
four autopsies
and stereotypes the alzheimer's disease
and progressive neuroposi are the most
common toxins
we actually have several ways for us to
distinguish toxins
the most
common way is by clinical features
such as dementia personality disorders
and movement disorders taking advantage
of
traditional emission tomography imaging
people could see the spatial and the
temporal distribution of tau inclusions
in centimeter levels when the patients
are still alive
the post-mortem neuropathology allow us
to see the antibody labeled or serious
stained towel inclusions in in tissue
sections at micrometer level
from 2017
by uh by uh croian by krajen
the
fundamental phenomena proteins could be
seen as atomic resolutions
in this talk i'd like to focus on how we
use prior em to
improve our understanding of topsis
in the past four years
my colleague has solved some of the
confidence structures
from alzheimer's disease chronic
traumatic estrophies
peak disease and cortical visual
degeneration
and they found the perfume structures
are different in
each disease however the the structures
from individuals with the same disease
is the same
therefore their observations that
distinct conformers of topic of
filamentous style define different top
cities
to have the overall view of the
relationship between the disease and
structure
we continue this crayon studies to
to
to other common policies especially the
full potential
the postgrad the postgraduate supreme
policy php is a full repeat
for repeat proxy
it is uh it is the
second most common topic is only after
azam disease which which is
characterized by both neuronal and glio
telepathologies where the enzyme disease
only or mainly have the neuronal
tau inclusions
the
movement disorder is the main symptoms
for the
typical pxp
patients
we have examined six
psp uh i will have examined the
confidence structure from six
psp pieces and found a
common
phenomenon fault
which we call the psp top vote
the psp portfolio spans repeat 2 p3
repeat 4 and several amino acids up to
repeat 4. and we also observe a
large actual densities in the central
cavity of the psp
fault and which is surrounded by three
livestreams and presumably corresponding
to
negatively charged molecules which could
stabilize the psp top fold
and clinically uh php is quite similar
to cbd
however
their fitment thoughts their topic
metaphors are different
the psp powerful has three layers while
the safety
top filaments fold in fully
therefore psp and cbd can be easily
distinguished by crier
the global layout of ggt is another for
repeated policies there are three
clinical subtypes of ggt we examine the
performance structures from one case of
gcd type one and one case of gtp type
two and found a common proton filament
ford
which we called
ggt tow fault
the ggt profiled is quite similar to psp
totals they
they both fold in three layers the
difference is that the
the
the c terminal of gcd top folds is
pointing to the
opposite direction and piping with the
end of repeat four
with a hairpin like structures
the actual philly green disease ajd is
another for pitopsies the defending
pathology
is the presence of abundant saturated
greens
we examined
the tophead structures from two hdd
cases and found a common
protofilament fort which we called hdd
top vote the hdd tophold also spans
repeat
two repeats three p four and seven
diamond glasses after p4 and it's quite
uh it's quite similar to
uh the cpd power port cb top fold
the the difference the difference are
the
arrangements between the three terminal
and antibiotics between hdd and the cpd
top fold and also the
the the three terminal of hd top for the
seven amino acids the cbd comfort
we also observe the hd total from three
other toxics they are aging related to
astrogliopsia attack
and two inherited from topsies
with the mutations as plus 3 or plus 16
in the interturn of the torching
to be noted that
previously it is not assigned to it it
never said that the plus 3 and plus 15
is related to
age and
these are these are the first structures
first top filament structures from the
inherited
cases with the mutations in the tau gene
and the above structure confidence
structures are from four repeat offices
we also we also in this study we also
we also examined the top element
structure from two inherited types three
are platformer autopsies and they are
familiar political dimension fbd and the
family damage dimension fdd
like azam disease spd and fcd are
characterized by both
extracellular
pathology and intra neuronal toxology
the the actual cellular pathology of bd
and fdd are made of a different protein
from a beta beta plaque in either
disease and causative mutations
at the
gene including the protein forming
extracellular
inclusions not in natural genes
we examine the confidence structure from
one case of spd and one case of fdd and
found the the confidence structure are
identical to alzheimer's disease
the crayon structure present in this
studies together with those described
previously
provide us the overarching perspective
and
which which set uh hierarchical
classifications of top states
based on their phenomena which we call
structure-based classifications
in the in the first level of
structure-based classifications
the uh the classification is based on
the
extent of outer core uh which which
coincides to
the
isoform-based classifications so the top
seeds can be classified as three apart
four autopsies
three autopsies and four top seeds
in a second level of classification in
the three are platform top seeds the
city comfort
is this is different from an azimuthal
thought
and ad spd ftd parts
are essentially the different process
which are characterized by
different symptoms or different
neuropathology however the tough
filaments structure in these diseases
are the same therefore they they are
they are classified as the same group
here also at the second level of the
classifications the four repeat purposes
can be classified
into two groups
the previously
found four layers first group and the
newly identified three layers thought
group
at the at the third level the third
level classifications
are
provided by a difference
in the difference at the residual levels
between the four layered food and
thriller food
the crayon study can not only
help us to classify the
process which we already know but also
could allow us to identify new topics
here is an example
we observe a different filament
structures
in the in a in a in a
patient uh who was diagnosed as psp
and since the since the structures are
since the structure is floating through
layers and
is similar to the ggt and the psp
we call this structure as jgt psp
comfort or gpt4
histologically this case was
subsequently found to be very different
from other
psp cases
where we found lots of spherical uh full
repeat neuronal inclusions in both
limbic and other brain regions
therefore we name this disease as
a limbic and predominant neuronal
inclusion body full repeats top 6 or lmt
so here comes the summary and by
uh core er
we solve the structures of top filaments
from psp gt ajd
rtx
plus three plus 16 fpd
brings and this finding stress the
theoretical classifications of toxins on
the basis of their filament force which
complements clinical diagnosis and
neuropathology
we also identified a new
topsy
int with the feedback structures
that are intimidated between those of
gdp and
psp
so in the end i would like to thank
people who have who helped me who helped
us to finish this this project
especially to
show service and michelle goodrich
who supervised this work
and when jian zhang is a
co-first author of this work and she
determined the top filament structures
from past three and 15 cases
yan yang provides the performance
structure from
rtec
spd and fdd cases
and i would like to also send ipea and
mike in german future scientific who
helped us to collect a
creation data which allow us to uh
to determine the crime structure of
of
gpt
fault as around 1.9 astronaut resolution
and i would like to also thank other
collaborators who provide us the brain
tissues the histology
data and clinical information
the imprint and uprisi for this studies
and also and thank you for your
attention
our next speaker is to fill up them she
will
she will discuss about the
individual side of the top filament
thank you yang
[Music]
yes so
yankee has been discussing all of the ex
vivo amyloid structures that we've been
solving from a patient's brain and this
has essentially
set a guide for us to sort of try and
recreate these disease structures but in
a test tube in vitro
and so
i'll be talking about the methods we've
been
using in order to actually make this
come true so this is actually using high
to put cryovm so that we can provide
model systems for neurodegenerative
diseases
and so just to reiterate a little bit of
what yangxia has been talking about
is this protein tau which is can form
these multiple different amyloid
filaments in neurodegenerative diseases
and here you can see the sequence the
protein sequence of tau and how it can
accommodate all of these different tau
folds which are specific to particular
diseases and what is sort of remarkable
from the studies that
we've been doing here at the mrc lmb
is that
a person with a particular disease for
example alzheimer's disease
and another person who's from a
different family
or elsewhere both has alzheimer's
disease will share the same
tau structure
however a person who's suffering from
plural supernuclear palsy or psp will
have a different structure so that there
is a clear structure disease
relationship which is sort of remarkable
and so we would like to recreate these
structures in vitro so that we can
perhaps try to understand these diseases
better
um so there are there are actually many
many reasons why you want to recreate
these disease structures so first of all
to understand why why are we getting
from a single polypeptide sequence all
of these different folds why are they
creating these folds and you can sort of
perturb your system to see why they are
sort of changing their behavior
according to one thing
and then perhaps also to study the
molecular events which are leading to
their assembly so protein folding in
general is sort of a big unknown and
it's very interesting field
so for amyloid certainly how
the protein can fold into these many
different folds is very
relevant question
and then the applications you can just
only start to imagine there are so many
applications that you can do
for example if you have a cellular model
you can perhaps understand how seeding
is occurring or spreading of these
filaments across
cells which happens in neurodegenerative
diseases you can also try to understand
how
filaments burden or filament's load
is affecting the cell so how is the cell
managing with having a lot of filaments
inside of it
and then on a larger scale or so for
animal models to understand near
degeneration at a whole because in
alzheimer's disease you have
near degeneration across the brain which
is leading to the clinical symptoms such
as memory loss
then for diagnostics currently
diagnosing alzheimer's disease is quite
difficult and usually find it find out
quite late
when the patient already has clinical
symptoms currently you rely on for
example measuring
tau or beta amyloid load in your
cerebral spinal fluid
or using positron emission tomography
in which you have ligands which can bind
to these filaments and sort of you can
image them and then see
if you have accumulations in certain
areas of the brain
however these ligands are currently not
very specific so if you have an in vitro
system we can generate huge amounts of
clean preparations to sort of
get higher binders for example and then
for nanobodies these can cross the
blood-brain barrier and are highly
specific so they can also be used as
biomarkers and then potentially when you
sort of link them all together to
understanding the molecular event you
can perhaps also
design inhibitors
which could perhaps prevent the spread
or prevent the initial state of
the amyloid formation
and so
um
here are all the the disease structure
or a few of the disease structures that
we have and essentially what you can see
is that tau is usually an intrinsically
disordered protein which binds to and
stabilizes microtubules however it can
form these very stable filaments that
can be quite versatile now what is
affecting this how is this changing and
there are many important considerations
that you need to take into account for
your experiments
for example your buffers your protein
concentrations your salt
for example and how do you test this in
a high throughput manner
because tweaking one thing
will mean that you're tweaking another
thing for example if you're changing
your protein concentration um you're
also
affecting the viscosity of the whole
solution if you're changing the salt you
have to take into the account the molar
concentration for example and then
temperature and shaking speeds the
physical factors are affecting the
chemical factors
so you need a high throughput method in
order to actually study this approach
study this
and so what we did was essentially um we
have a very easy way of purifying tau
which can be can go quite quickly so you
can purify tau within two to three days
um huge amounts about 100 milligrams
which is a lot for proteins per liter
um and you can then we just use cation
exchange and size exclusion to purify it
now this is very important that you have
very pure preps for
protein assembly reactions you can then
assemble them using all of the the
ranges that um i just discussed chemical
factors or physical factors
and then we solve their structures so
abbey already mentioned how
we went about screening the samples so
you could screen lots of samples very
quickly
and then on short sphere side of of the
lab we're interested in software
development and he's managed to
implement sort of automated picking
algorithms better tools for 3d
reconstruction for amyloid filaments
which has made this whole idea that
query vm is no longer the bottleneck but
moreover the experimentalist in a way
that you sort of um you have to push
in order to
get everything through
and so
this is sort of just
what we found
um this
essentially
we found that amyloid studies
require high throughput chromium
this the all of these structures here i
think there are about 76 in here
just highlight that tau is extremely
versatile and it can form many many
different folds and it doesn't suffice
to essentially solve one structure under
one condition because it will tell you
nothing for amyloids it's important to
do comparisons and
solving all of these structures allowed
us to actually determine
what are the important
important factors your physical physical
factors and chemical factors
for generating actual relevant filaments
that you get in disease and not
irrelevant random filaments that we we
don't really care about
and so
here is essentially what we found so
reconstituting the in vitro paired
helical filaments in alzheimer's disease
essentially what we did is we made a
construct to limit the sequence of tau
this sequence is not this concept is not
new it was already described in the 90s
as there were antibodies that were
directed towards the sea terminal
region of tau so this 391 sequence
and then we used um
approaches described in al-hilali ital
paper 2017
however we found that structures
did not recapitulate the structures that
you get in alzheimer's disease
and so i essentially started playing
around with different conditions and
then found that just by changing a
physical factor you could
recreate to some extent the paired
helical filaments that you get in
alzheimer's disease and so we then
started playing around a bit more
trying different conditions to try and
get better populations of the
alzheimer's fall which you can see here
um and in the end we managed to
get
pure alzheimer's disease like filaments
and this is just to show you that they
are indeed identical so these filaments
are now incredibly clean and you can use
them for any purpose that you want
and so we then came
what are the sequence requirements is
this actually a special concentrate that
we just you know we sort of got very
lucky in a way
um and we should be looking deeply into
this and so
we went through a series of different
constructs to sort of test uh tau um and
when when it's forming these correct
structures and this really highlights
that you need high throughput approaches
to enable to solve this many structures
and so here i've shown you the sequence
of tau
again and the x marks essentially it
doesn't form filament a green tick means
it forms the correct filaments
using our conditions
the orange line means it forms filaments
but not necessarily the correct ones the
blue dot means the correct
protofilament but not the correct
filaments so you have two
um only one c shape for example
so what we found is that you can form
the correct filaments by essentially
extending quite substantially in both
directions but then towards the end
termness it started to become more fuzzy
and we have to do more work to
essentially understand
what's happening but what was very
interesting is that there are certain
regions in the tau sequence that are
inhibitory and we're sort of exploring
what what that sequence is
if you
potentially modify it in some way can
you still
form the correct structures and that is
sort of where the study is leading on to
now
then when we were
solving the the structures using the
different conditions
we noticed that when i changed the the
ion in the buffer
i was actually
recreating a structure from a different
disease so
here you can see that i've been adding
lithium sodium chloride potassium
chloride or magnesium chloride and we
notice that a certain region in tau
which we call the head region
was actually changing
the cavity of
the structure and what we found is that
you got additional densities inside
this head cavity when you included
an ion for example however not with
magnesium
chloride it could not fit into the
structure
and so
essentially we we noticed that we could
recreate um filament from chronic
traumatic encephalopathy so this disease
or we call it not cte
is a disease which is from recurrent
concussions so for example football play
american football players or
boxing types of diseases people can get
this disease
and so
essentially the conclusion is the
addition of salts dictate the structure
of the head cavity of the filament and
so this does not necessarily tell you
for certain that the
the this ion is important for this
disease but it could tell you that
some ions are actually important for um
filament assembly and these sorts of
things
and so your conditions are instrumental
for
the structure that you're forming so
this is something to keep in mind for
the amyloid field
and so
um
i think
for th this study has essentially solved
so many tau structures and i think
what's what has really been highlighted
from what yang has been also showing us
and what our colleagues in the amyloid
field as well
is that
for amyloids
one sequence does not equal one
structure
um one sequence of tau can form multiple
different structures and
the list is essentially endless and i
think we've essentially just scraped the
top of it at the moment and there's so
much more to discover but this is sort
of also really exciting in a way that it
can sort of defy this whole protein
folding
and so
we are now trying to understand the
molecular events which are
leading to it to form certain folds and
when when it would not go to a certain
fold
to sort of understand it
there are a lot of people that i would
like to thank for this
especially my two
pis michelle hooters and george here's
at the mrc lmb
um also from thermafisher abbey adrian
and bart
for
helping me with acquiring lots of data
and
essentially collecting lots of data as
well
there are so many more people to thank
but essentially everyone who's been
present
my funders ukri mrc at the lmb as well
thank you
welcome back everyone
thank you for attending so far and it's
now time for our question answer session
if you have any additional questions
please submission your question through
the q a window
it looks like we have some questions
already
so
the first question um
how do you make sure the filaments from
the brain remain
during purification that there are no
purification artifacts
i think maybe sophia you could answer
this for us um yeah sure so essentially
um
how do you make sure that filaments from
brain remains intact during purification
well essentially we'll extract them
using sarcasyl
or parkour and soluble methods so we
spin them down and then we look at them
by cryo-em of course because this is
from brain samples there is usually lots
of things but luckily for using query m
you can select what you look at so you
essentially look only at the filament so
of course you have artifacts in there
that are just natural products from the
brain as you're extracting them
um we know that they remain intact
because we wouldn't be able to solve
their structures if they were not intact
essentially
okay
i want to add a point
after after sofia
is
we actually try to use the immuno
purification
for
adi tork filaments and i will solve the
structure of that and found the
the structures i
identical to the
structure insoluble top filament so so
so i think the successor will not affect
the
structure at least for the
for the outer core of the top filament
that's the answer
okay
um and then how do you image scripts
that how often do image grids that
contain mostly damaged liberals
um
i think for the for the fullest talk
there are huge amounts of
peptides which are
which are forming we call fatty coat the
father code is actually the unstructured
peptides which are floating around the
outer core which can protect the
filament
filament from the aero water interface
during the
ammo grid mickey so i think for the
fuller style
it's very rare to have the
to have the damaged
filament
in another way
we could think if for the brain sample
for the human
patient grab
sample
if you see another kind of filament is
different from
what you expect and it it's very hard to
to to tell if if they are damaged
fabrics or there are another fabulous
before your
softer structure so i think
for the fullness tower
from the
human brain
it is quite rare to have the damage
fitment
okay
thank you
okay next question
how one seeks how can one sequence
result in a multiple structure is it
that there are multiple pseudostable
metastable structures from the protein
folding size
i'm going to kind of addition and can
you predict the sequence
so that is the whole thing about this
protein right
that's a whole strange thing on a lot of
intrinsically disordered proteins when
they're in cells they're sort of
have multiple worlds multiple functions
so
um they they need to be this disorder so
that they can
sort of do this and then
um
because of this as well they they are
also susceptible to misholding in lots
of different ways as well so
um this this is a very important
question and we we don't know why
it can form all these different
structures
that's sort of something that we're
studying at the moment or trying to
understand at least using
quarry m but also other techniques such
as nmr
great thanks
um next question um
how was screen
uh what screening was required um for
these towel filaments
uh
if for the brain direct
uh top filaments actually
we should do the
for example western blood first to to
test which uh patient or which
regions uh
uh have many pathologies and afterwards
we do negatively
staining and creating uh crying
screening to
to to find a
perfect grade to to collect the data
okay thanks
all right another question
how do amyloid plaques affect the brain
i'm not sure who wants to take this
or me
yeah i don't know who i should answer
but yeah go ahead maybe
i think so far
uh
uh
for the for the amino text is it's made
by
abet proteins
obviously a
alzheimer's disease
it is actual cellular and pathology
so far i think
uh
there's one possibility is that uh the
aggregated a beta plagues will
physically
interact with the
neuron neurons or glial cells to
damage the cells and other than that i
have an idea
yeah
there is a stronger correlation for
tau pathology and neurodegeneration
which is why we focus mostly on tau but
in alzheimer's disease you do have both
beta-amyloid and
blacks coming and it's this is very
characteristic of ad
okay
uh
thanks for that
um will you ever be able to use crayon
to solve oligomer structures or can it
just be used for the final fibral
structure
so oligomers is a very difficult um sort
of term so for those who aren't very
familiar with sort of how these amyloids
form there's the theory is is that
they're sort of intrinsically disordered
and then you get accumulation of more of
the same protein that form these
oligomers now what an oligomer is
we don't really know some people
describe them as globular-like type of
things or more
very small fibrils or these sorts of
things
they're considered to be the toxic
species by for some people and then some
people believe that there are elements
but
there's still a lot of research on going
with this
whether you can solve an oligomer using
query m that depends on how structured
it is so first of all aquarium relies on
having
a structure if the oligomer is sort of
dynamic
too dynamic or
multiple different or thousands of
different confirmations you won't be
able to solve it with
um query m unfortunately
and if they're too small as well um you
know sub 50 40 kilodaltons you won't be
able to solve those either
by aquarium but by nmr you you can but
you can otherwise if they were
structured
um yes you can
okay thank you
um i think this next question is
probably for up high um it was recently
reported you know that there are
multiple structures at two and a half
angstrom resolution which is some rare i
think compared to other parts of results
that are seen around the world
uh like this first one i said it says
that they use the kryos g4 and g1 with
the k3 camera epu and legionnon um and
that they're seeing f
angstrom three and a half or sorry three
three resolution angstrom
um
what is the bottleneck for reaching that
high of a resolution like two and a half
angstrom
that's that is actually a very difficult
question to answer in a few minutes here
um i could just speak for hours on this
um
there are several factors actually uh it
number one it depends on the sample uh
if sample is very flexible then then you
are actually limited by your
sample flexibility uh but also the type
of goods that you are using can have
some impacts the ice that you have on
your grid
has some effects uh then
if if all those things are fine then we
come on to the microscope
it's all about getting very high signal
to noise
and this is why i think we feel that we
are getting this kind of resolution um
when we first got such a resolution with
epipheratone in 2020 we published this
1.2 angstrom structure
we also wanted to test that is it just
limited to
epithelium or can we look at so many
different uh samples and this is what we
are doing over the last two years
uh we looked at membrane proteins which
were like sub-hundred production bigger
membrane proteins we are looking at
these tower filaments
and you are right that in every cases we
are able to produce these high
resolution structures
but that is also because
we are screening we are making sure that
samples are good the ice is good uh and
then how to collect the data as well and
also how the data is processed
um what i would suggest is
reach out to me by email and then maybe
we can arrange a poll to to do
more deeper dive
into your collection your sample your
how your goods are looking like your
collection parameters and then your
database
okay
thanks for that answer
i think maybe in a similar
question it's something
related to throughput so can you explain
in a few sentences how you're creating
more has more throughput than previous
approaches um
algorithms that were developed
but i couldn't hear that question
properly can you read that okay can you
explain in a few sentences how you made
your crying more i mean higher
throughput than previous approaches uh
were there certain algorithms developed
sure so again for report
number one throughput is a very complex
thing uh in in
just few years ago like we were
collecting data at something like
50 60 images per hour
but it also depends on on what
magnification you are using what flux
that you want to use the total dose that
you are using all this will uh determine
your exposure time and exposure time
then leads to your throughput
but we we also did so many changes on on
the hardware side so for example we
recently released falcon 4i
uh that that is a faster detector
running at 320 frames per second um also
we reduced all the
lag time all the all the date time that
that camera was waiting now epu was
waiting all this thing is reduced um
from like 2.5 percent to like 0.5
percent so that gives you more
throughput you can use higher flux with
falcon 4i then your exposure time is
reduced
um in addition on the optics side we
have fringe free imaging as well as
aberration free image shift so you don't
need to move your stage quite a lot
and when you combine all these things
together um on on the cryos for example
some of the structures some of these
data are collected on the cryos and we
were running at 500 600 images per hour
and on the glaciers uh right now we are
running between like 250 to 300 uh
movies per hour this is at a
magnification of about 0.8 angstrom
pixel
if you go
higher meg so for example in case of
apopheritin uh we were running even
higher like we were running at 600 700
images per hour on the cryos and 400
images per hour on the glaciers so if
it's a balance you have to see what
sample you are using uh
what kind of setup you have what kind of
detectors and optics you have a
combination of all this will dictate
your throughput
okay
thank you
okay i think the next question is uh
alpha fold so the question is that can
you use alpha fold to get these
structures
for ads
no
[Music]
simple answer if you if you put the
sequence in alpha fold you get spaghetti
if you put two sequences you get more
spaghetti and
yeah it simply does not work because the
same sequence can create multiple
structures it's not surprising that
alpha fold cannot do this nor i believe
has also been trained on
sort of our types of system you probably
need a whole new way of thinking for
or yeah generating
something like that yeah
okay thanks for that
all right um next question ed do you
think that the in vitro conditions you
use to assemble the different
recombinant tau structures
likely represent the physiological
conditions under which the different
structures form in the brain
no so
um it's a good question um
so these are
these are highly controlled uh
environments that we use in the test
tube whereas in the brain
there are lots of things going on in
your cells it's a very crowded
environment you've got influx affects
and
there are probably multiple different
ways in which tao could miss fall to
form the alzheimer's disease paired
helical filament fold whereas in the
test tube you have to have quite
um
very specific conditions to form the
correct fold so
the fact that i use magnesium these
kinds of things in my test tube is
probably not at all what's happening in
alzheimer's disease
so
it's probably very different things
going on this is simply just a procedure
that you can recreate these structures
not a
mechanism of how alzheimer's might work
okay
thank you
next question
do the treatments differ
for the different towel filaments
how does the understanding of what tau
filament
patient has
changed for the therapeutic process
the the treatments are the same when
purifying the top filament i think
the observation
we have suggested that
the
top proteins can be a very good
uh
detector
to detect the the
minor
environmental changes in the
in the patient's brains and the the very
very tiny
uh chemical or
post translational modification changes
will
change the
tau filament structures
which can be a good
indicator for the disease
okay
thank you
next question
what is the limitation of crying
compared to nmr
or crystallography methods
so
um nmr is um
better for looking at sort of the
soluble state so pre-amyloid formation
so you can look at
sort of
the disorder of the protein if it's
forming alpha helices and solution just
how the protein might behave in solution
you can then um use query m to solve
structures of how it might look like in
a filament state um
you can't do that with solutions to nmr
but you can do it with solid state nmr
however
not to the high throughput as you can
with cryoam
then crystallography you can't you can
crystallize small peptides that can form
amyloid but not i don't think it's ever
been done on sort of a full-length
towel or something to form um i don't
think you can form crystals of those but
i might be wrong but
um yeah so
each method has their perks but um
there's definitely more methods required
to sort of study the whole in-between
states that are quite complicated for
all methods but currently for the
intermediate states nmr combination of
nmr and crm can be useful
okay thank you
do you know how crowders may affect
tao's assembly
can you paint it how crap
crowders may affect um how the assembly
of the town
um
oh um
no we have not really tried
crowding much using pegs and things we
haven't really tried um to the extent
that we want to try but it is something
we want to try and work on a bit more
more as well yeah
okay
um
comment on you know what is the
biological of the significance of the
structures you've solved
very open question but have savings and
yeah firstly the the structures we saw
and could have had to classify the
freedom of autopsies and also could help
us to identify
new autopsies or neural
neurodegenerative diseases by the human
force
another thing is
for the in the high resolution
structures
we could find
some actual densities or non-proteinases
densities which can be a
perfectors in the in the cells in the
human brains
which would suggest that
these cofactors
might play a very important role for the
filament formation and which will be our
next target
to
to see if these
extra densities
how these as that extra densities affect
the phenomena formation and why the
extra density
is there
okay
all right thanks uh next question
uh during helical reconstruction do you
use higher t number in the 3d auto
refine job
um and then the second part of the
question is do you follow the same
workflow for all helical reconstruction
for all filaments like your recombinant
data set
for the t value part
we usually don't use
high t values for 3d autorefine
we only use it for more difficult cases
of for the reconstructions when when
refinements don't necessarily work we
might try and put a t t-value on to see
if it might
fold into place
for the second part of the question
do you follow the same workflow for all
the helico reconstruction
very similar it depends on the crossover
of the filament that you have so
initially i've we've written a
an additional paper to describe all the
necessary steps that we took for this
high throughput
paper that we had in e-life
essentially we did follow the same
the the same workflow but if you have a
filament that has a long crossover we
might sort of play around a little bit
more than what we would because these
these structures tend to be more
difficult to solve
um so
i would recommend that you see that
paper because that is essentially
describing the workflow
that we would usually do and the
different steps we may take depending on
a certain data set
um
yeah
you can find it
okay sounds good i think this will be
our last question
um
oh maybe
appeared here what
sorry for this um
what is the throughput on the glaciers
and the highest resolution achieved at
the glacier
yeah by this question for you i think i
can answer it um again like uh
throughput does depend on what kind of
setup you are using and that's your
magnification flux uh and and total dose
that you are using uh for this
particular case uh all the tower paths
uh structure that we reported in e-life
recently
the throughput was between 250 to 270
images per hour
and each data set were collected for
about eight hours and in one session we
collected eight datasets using this uh
multi-grid approach that we are using on
a glaciers
and in terms of resolution uh with
glaciers uh most structures wear sub
three angstroms but in range between
like
2.6 angstroms to i think 3.2 or
something sophia you can correct me if
if i'm wrong are the glaciers yeah
around 2.6 to 3.3 yeah yeah
okay well thank you very much for
presentation today and
all of you attending
um before we go um i would say any
questions that we didn't have time to
answer will be addressed via email
and this webcast and others in our
electron microscopy series can be viewed
on demand on lab routes you can also
register for our upcoming sessions
we encourage that you share this session
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
if you still need more cryo-em in your
day please visit our learning center at
thermofisher.com forward slash cryo-em
you can check out recent publications
watch more talks on demand like our ask
the expert series or contact us contact
us here if you have additional questions
thank you very much to our speakers
and
especially to all of you for joining us
today until next time
bye
you